[Musique]
alors simplement si vous avez été
beaucoup critiqués parce vous raconter
quand vous inculper christine villemin
vous pleurez avant vous dites voilà j'ai
plus horrible une fois qu'elle est
inculpé vous pleurez encore après et
vous dites même que cela perturbe votre
vie sexuelle
bon moi j'ai trouvé bon il ya des gens
qui se moquent de cet aveu moi pas très
franchement je trouve que c'est que
beaucoup de courage pour avouer ce genre
de choses parce qu'effectivement c'est
on s'en moque assez facilement les
larmes la juge d'instruction
quelqu'un qui vient n'est qu'une inculpé
et puis même c'est cette inculpation qui
vient troubler sa vie intime tout ça est
un et se préparer moi j'ai plutôt été un
peu émue l'a plutôt que payer un assez
pitoyable le parlent par le rôle que
tient le juge est parée par cette
mission qui finalement je crois que la
vraie question c'est de savoir si
monsieur mais où jean michel lambert
était fait pour être juge d'instruction
alors quelle est la réponse et il vous
fait pour être juge d'instruction - le
sentiment que oui et et qui est pensez
vous pas que cette affaire est arrivé
trop tôt dans votre vie professionnelle
ou peut-être peut-être mais ça c'est une
affaire comme ça
on en rencontre une fois tous les 20 ou
30 ans est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
justement dans votre livre avec la
candeur qui aux caractérisques que
justement vos professeurs à l'école ou
quand vous avez passé aucun examen ont
précisé qu'il n'était pas fait pour ce
métissage est aussi lui seul a rebondi
toutefois à non non non je les lui à
voilà moi je les nie mondiale a renchéri
et sage jusqu'à preuve du contraire
alors la capitale
[Musique]